ebola has come to new york and we were
expecting it it was only a matter of
time and of course the hospitals had
been preparing they've been doing dry
runs for something like this but now we
know the details this man came over he
was working in guinea he was working
with doctors without borders and he uh
didn't feel any kind of fever or fatigue
until very recently he'd been taking his
temperature twice a day as a protocol
has it
we've been i want to say this we've been
talking about this brendan greeley
you've been doing it what was your your
inclination as you read of isolation so
the key here is to look at the
difference between the way doctors
without borders handle this because they
actually do treatment in countries where
their ebola outbreaks and the way the
cdc handles it what you're seeing is the
difference between calling the doctors
without borders and saying you have a
fever and calling the cdc and as you see
the cdc develop and improve its
procedures this is what bellevue is
doing now what they're really doing is
adopting what doctors without borders
has always i want to frame for our
global audience if you're at columbia
physicians and surgeons columbia p s as
dr spencer is you can't pick a better
hospital in america and certainly
typically right now at bellevue started
in 1763 the first maternity award they
made popular the syringe they own
emergency care as he goes in there uh
last night scott well he did also have
contact with several people not that
many but three others and there's also a
driver because he took an uber
after he went bowling apparently and
uber has put out a statement saying that
neither our driver partner nor any of
our uh
any of his subsequent passengers are at
risk specifically he says we've provided
our records and we're able to confirm
that one of our driver partners in new
york provided a ride to the patient
yesterday evening we immediately
contacted the necessary
organizations and the necessary uh
departments which stated that neither
driver partnered or any of his
subsequent passengers are at risk we're
learning as we go here this is we're in
we are we're in a place with ebola where
we've never been before and one thing
that you're also seeing is uh brad
weiner is he's writes for he's an editor
of bloomberg business week he's with
doctors without borders right now
reporting on a feature in brussels and
he emailed me last night to say that
they have already changed their own
protocol you now are automatically if
you work for the organizations in
quarantine for 21 days
rather than allowed to travel rather
than allowed to travel so we're already
changing so this is not going to happen
again in the future we already know that
you're not allowed to come home take an
uber go bowling go back to your
apartment so this is we're changing as
it goes and that's the thing i mean he
knew that he had been somewhere that was
high risk and yet when he came back he
didn't have a temperature so he could
continue with his normal life right it's
when you have a temperature that you are
contagious is that correct it's when you
have a temperature that you contain you
are not contagious until you start to
show symptoms but who wants to titrate
that exactly and figure out exactly how
long you do the point of titrate in the
virology of ebola and must be speaking
folks through bloomberg surveillance
this morning to medical experts on this
i also worry about a changing virus the
distinction between a virus and a
bacterium is you get a lot of change and
surprise as the virus moves along i
don't want to be inflammatory but that's
got to be front and center here i feel
like the virus as it is is bad enough
right yeah we do not have a handle on
what's happening now brendan isn't the
distinction here that the ebola is not
like malaria or something like that more
widespread it's if you get it you're at
huge risk if you get it you're rich but
i mean honestly the worst thing that
i've read about this is about two weeks
old it's an essay in slate that it says
the problem with ebola is that it robs
you of your humanity if your child gets
it you cannot touch your child and care
for your child i think that's what's
heartbreaking about this